Hello world.
It's it Raj.
Geoffrey Hinton is one of the
godfathers of deep learning.
In the 80s he popularized the
backpropagation algorithm,
which is the reason deep
learning works so well,
and he believed in the idea of neural
networks during the first major AI winter
in the 80s while everyone else
didn't think that they would work,
and that's why he's awesome.
But anyway,
Hinton recently published a paper
on this idea of a capsule network,
which he's been hinting at for a long
time. Hinting Hinton was hinting, yeah,
he's been hinting at this for a long time
in the machine learning subreddit and
talks that he's been doing,
but a few days ago he finally
published the paper for it.
So I was very excited to read it
and talk about it. But anyway,
but it offers state of the art
performance on the m and ist a Dataset,
which is the handwritten character
dataset. It's kind of the baseline.
You probably know about it if
you've done any kind of AI before,
but it's those handwritten characters
classifying them as the digits that they
are,
and it become delusional networks at this.
And convolutional networks
are the state of the art.
So it's a really exciting time right now.
And what this video is,
is me talking about what the state
of the art algorithm currently is,
the convolutional network,
all the developments that have
happened in convolutional networks.
Then we'll talk about
capsules and how they work,
and we'll end the video with me going
through the tensorflow code of a capsule
network, right? So here's an image
of a convolutional neural network.
And if we use a standard multilayer
perceptron with all the layers fully
connected to each other,
it would quickly become computationally
intractable because images are very high
dimensional, right?
There's lots of pixels.
And if we are continuously applying these
operations to every single pixel in an
image and every layer,
it's going to take way too long.
So the solution to this is was
to use a convolutional network.
And this was really popularized by young
Macoun who is now director of AI at
Facebook in the early nineties but the
convolutional network looks like this,
right? So first we have
an input image, right?
The input image has an associated label.
So if it's a picture of
a car like we see here,
then it's going to have an associated
label, which is car, right?
So picture of a car and then car.
And you do that for an entire Dataset.
And what a convolutional network will
do is it will learn the mapping between
the input data and the output label.
And so the idea is that eventually
you'll give it a picture of a car after
training and it will know, hey, that's
a car because it's learned the mapping.
When we first feed this network a car,
it's going to first be applied
to the convolutional layer.
And so in the convolutional layer,
it's basically a series of Matrix
multiplications followed by a summation
operation. And I have a video on
how convolutional networks worked,
really in depth that I'm going to link
to in the video description under more
learning resources. But right
now I'm going to go over
it at a high level, right?
So in a convolutional layer,
it's kind of like a flashlight.
It's which is being applied over
every single pixel in the image.
And it's looking for the most
relevant parts of that image.
And so it's a multiplication
and a summation operation.
But basically the convolution layer
will output a feature map. The these,
this feature map represents a bunch of
features that it's learned from that
image, right? So a set of features
that are represented by matrices.
And so once we have these features that
are learned by this filtering operation,
then we're going to apply a non linearity
to it, like a rectified linear unit,
for example. And when we apply
a nonlinearity to it, it's,
it serves a lot of purposes.
The first purpose is so that the network
can learn both linear and nonlinear
functions, right? Because neural networks
are universal function approximators.
But this for, for rectified
linear unit in particular, uh,
one of the reasons for using that
as opposed to the other types of
nonlinearities is because it allows to
be is because it solves the vanishing
gradient problem during backpropagation.
So when we forward
propagate through a network,
we are performing a series of operations.
We find the output a class probability,
we compare that to the actual label,
we compute an error value and we
use the error to compute a gradient.
And a gradient tells us how to update
our weights as we back propagate it
through the network.
And what the,
what really does is it says it helps
solve the vanishing gradient problem
because sometimes as a
gradient is back propagating,
it gets smaller and smaller and
smaller so that the weight update is,
is smaller and smaller. And this is not
good. We want, we want a big way update,
right? We don't want that weight update
to vanish. And so relu helps prevent that,
that gradient from vanishing.
And so at the end of this convolutional
block is the pooling operation.
So let's say you have a matrix, right?
And inside of that Matrix of pixel values,
you have a bunch of numbers,
right?
For Pixel intensity is between zero
and two 55 and what what pooling does,
like Max pooling for example,
is it says let's create sections for
all of these different pixel values and
let's only take the maximum pixel value
from each section and propagate that
forward.
So it's a smaller section
that's propagated forward
and this and this increases
and it speeds up the training time.
And so if we look at comp nets,
they're actually, you know,
anyone can really implement a
convolutional network these days, right?
With libraries like carrots, which are
very high level, anyone can implement,
implement a very powerful convolutional
network and just a few lines of code
where each line of code corresponds
to a layer in the network.
So it's actually, it's, it's
very easy these days to do that.
And a lot of people can do that nowadays,
right? So once you define your network,
each layer with its own line of code,
then you can compile it,
you can define the optimizer and the,
and the loss function.
You'll train it with the fit function
and then you can evaluate it on your
testing data.
So I've got this huge graphic here of
the modern history of object recognition,
which I'm not going to
go into in detail here,
but it's definitely something to check
out after you watch this video because
I've got the link to this on my
slides in the video description,
but it's a really detailed image of the
history of convolutional networks across
all the different images,
all the different image net competitions,
and all the improvements
that have been made.
But I will go through some that I
think are really, really significant.
So one of the first
improvements to CNNs w, uh,
was the Alex net a network,
which was in 2012. Right?
So there were some key improvements here.
So the first one was an introduced
three Lw, which I talked about,
which helps prevent the
vanishing gradient problem.
It also introduced the concept of dropout.
So dropout is a technique where neurons
are randomly turned on and off in each
layer to prevent over fitting.
So if your data is too homogenous,
it's not going to be able to classify
images that are similar but different
because it's, it's to fit, it's
overfit to your training data.
So dropout is a regularization technique
that prevents overfitting by randomly
turning neurons on and off.
And by doing this,
the data is forced to find
new pathways to go through,
and because it's forced
to find new pathways,
the network is able to generalize better.
It also introduced the idea of data
augmentation. So convolutional networks,
as awesome as they are,
they're really bad at detecting they're
really bad at classifying images if
they're in different rotations
or if they're upside down.
It's got to be in the kind of exact spot
that it was trained on or very close to
it. So what Alex Net did, or the w,
so what the author of Alex
and that did is he input,
he fed in different rotations of images
into Alex net than just the single
rotation, and that made it able to
generalize better to different rotations.
Lastly, it was a deeper network.
So they just added on more layers.
And this improved the
classification accuracy.
After that there was VGG net, which was
a major improvement. And the really,
the only big difference there
was them adding more layers.
That was it really a after that
there was Google in that, right?
So for Google and as it looks like this,
but convolutions with different filters,
sizes are pro were processed on the
same input and then can concatenate it
together.
So in a single layer,
rather than going through
just one convolutional
operation or set of operations,
remember it's multiplications
and then a summation operation.
It's several of those together, right?
So it's multiplying some multiplying,
some multiplying some,
and then it takes the outputs of all
of those and then it can catenate those
together. And that's what it
propagates forward. And by doing this,
it allowed it to learn better
feature representations at each,
at each layer. Right? So,
and then there was resonant
and so resonant was,
the idea behind resonate was, well,
if we just keep stacking layers,
is the network get better every time?
And the answer was no,
it's good up to a certain point.
And then if you add more,
there's a drop in performance.
So what resonant said was, okay,
we know that there is some optimal limit
to the number of layers we should add.
So after every two layers, let's add
this element wise addition operation.
So it just added this operation and
this improved gradient propagation.
This made backpropagation easier and
it helped further improve the vanishing
gradient problem. And after that there
was dense net and dense net propose,
uh, connecting entire blocks
of layers to one another.
So it was a more complex
connection scheme. So, um,
there are some patterns here,
right?
So there's some patterns here
for all of these networks.
The networks are designed to be deeper
and deeper and there's also computational
tricks that are being added onto these
convolutional networks like relu or drop
out or batch normalization that
improved performance. And lastly,
there is an increasing use of connections
between the layers of the network.
But Hinton said, okay, there is a
problem with convolutional networks.
So remember that convolutional networks
learn to classify images, right?
So in the lower low it's Lael.
So in the lowest layers of a convolutional
network, it's going to learn the,
the lowest level features of what
it's seeing. So for dogs for example,
in the lowest layer,
it's going to learn the edges and the
curvature of your ear and that the
curvature of the dog's ear, maybe
like a single tooth. And then as we,
as we go up the hierarchy as in,
as we, as we go to the next layer,
and then the next layer,
each of the features that it's
learning are going to be more complex.
So in the first layer of their edges
and the next layer they're going to be
shapes and the next layer they're going
to be more complex shaped like an entire
year. And then finally in the last
layer, they're going to be very,
very complex shapes like the entire body
of a dog, for example. Right. And this,
this is very similar to how
the human visual cortex works.
We know for certain that there is
some kind of hierarchy happening.
Whenever we look at something that's,
there's this hierarchy of
neurons that are firing in order.
When we tried to recognize something
that we see that that's the high level of
what we know.
We don't know the exact intricate
details of how the routing mechanism is
between layers, but we do know that there
is some kind of hierarchy happening.
Tween each layer rights.
So there is a problem with convolutional
networks though. There are two reasons.
First of all,
sub sampling loses the precise spatial
relationships between higher level parts
such as a nose and a mouth,
right?
So it's not enough to just be able to
classify a nose and a mouth, right?
It's like if you have a nose in the left
corner of an image and then you have a
mouth in the right corner of an image
and then you have eyes at the bottom,
you can't just say, oh, it has these
three features. It must be a face. No,
there's also a spatial correlation.
The eyes have to be above the nose,
which have to be above
the mouth, right? So,
but sub sampling or pooling
loses this relationship. Uh,
and also they can't extrapolate their
understanding of geometric relationships
to radically new viewpoints.
Like I said before,
convolutional networks are really bad at
detecting an image if it's in any kind
of different position, right? If
it's rotated, if it's upside down,
if it's to the left, to the right, it's
gotta be in the kind of general, uh,
position that it was of the images that
are trained on. And this is a problem,
right? The idea is that instead
of invariants, we should be,
we should be striving for Echo variants,
right?
So the original goal of sub sampling
or pooling, it's the same thing.
Sub sampling or pooling is it tries to
make the neural activities in variant to
small changes in, in
viewpoint, right? So, uh,
what that means is no matter what,
rotate, what position or rotation,
some images in the neural
network responds in the same way.
The data flow is the same,
but it's better to aim for ECQUA variants.
That means that if we rotate an image,
the neural network should also change.
It should also adapt to how it's
learning from this image or how it's
processing. This image. So we need,
so what we need is a network that's more
robust to to changes in two changes in
transformations of how images
are positioned and we need,
we also need networks that are more
easily able to generalize, right? That's,
that's just the general thing.
And all of Ai,
we need algorithms that are more able to
generalize to data that it's never seen
before based on what it's trained on.
And also there's one more thing.
There's a 66 day old paper on
convolutional networks that just came out,
which is a pixel attack for fooling
deep neural networks. Basically,
the authors found that they could tweak
just a few pixels in an image that
otherwise looks exactly like a, a
perfect classification, like a dog,
that it would,
that it would predict perfectly,
but by just changing these few pixels,
they found that the entire network's
classification was, was really bad.
And this is a problem, right? That's the,
that's just not how it should be. That's,
it doesn't make sense that it's that
it's that separable twin attack. Right.
If we're thinking about, if we're
thinking about creating self driving cars,
right? These huge machines that are
flying across the road and they're,
they're using computer
vision to detect things,
they can't be susceptible to these
kinds of a pixel attacks, right?
They've got to be very robust.
So Hinton introduced this
idea of the capsule network,
and here is an image of it,
but the kind of the basic idea that
Hinton had was the human brain much must
achieve translational in
variants in a much better way.
It's got to do something
other than pooling.
And he posits that the brain has
these modules that he calls capsules,
which are really good at handling
different types of visual,
visual stimulus and in coding
things in a certain way.
So CNNs do routing by pooling,
they route how data is transferred across
each layer by this pooling operation,
right? So if, if we input an
image, we apply a convolution,
a convolutional operation to it,
and then a nonlinearity,
and then we pull it based on what
the output of that pooling layer is,
the image is going to go in a certain
for the next layer, right? Uh,
but it's going to hit certain units
in the next layer based on pooling.
But pooling is a very crude
way to route data, right?
There's gotta be a
better way to route data.
So the basic basic idea behind a capsule
network is it's just a neural network
where instead of just
adding another layer, right?
So usually we're adding
different types of layers.
It instead it nests a
new layer inside a layer.
So that's all it is. It's
where instead of saying, okay,
we've got this single layer neural
network, let's add a different layer. No,
inside of that layer,
let's add another layer.
So it's a nested layer
inside an inside of a layer.
And that nested layer is called a capsule,
which is a group of neurons.
And so a typical layer of neurons or
units becomes a layer of capsules.
So instead of making the ne the network
deeper in the sense of height or I guess
you could even say with,
it's making a deeper in terms of
nesting or inner structure and that's,
that's all it is basically.
And this model is more
robust to transformations
in terms of rotation or how
this image is, I mean it is chief
state of the art for m and ist,
which is a really,
it's a big deal.
We'll see how it scales later on to to
you know, really, really huge datasets.
But for M and ist, that's,
that's, that's a pretty big deal.
So the capsule network has two really
key features and the first one is layer
based squashing.
And the second one is dynamic routing.
So in a typical neural network,
only the output of a single unit is
squashed by a nonlinearity. Right?
So we have a set of output neurons
and the based on the output of each,
we apply a nonlinearity to each of them.
So instead of applying a nonlinearity
to each individual neuron,
we grouped these neurons into a capsule
and apply nonlinearity to the entire set
of neurons.
The vector of those neurons.
And so when we apply nonlinearity,
it's, it's to the entire layer, right?
Instead of individual neurons and
also implements a dynamic routing.
So instead of,
uh,
so it's replaces the scalar output feature
detectors of CNNS with vector output
capsules,
and it replaces Max pooling
by routing by agreement.
So each of these capsules in each layer,
when they forward propagate data,
it goes to the next
most relevant capsules.
So it's kind of like a hierarchical
tree of nested layers inside of layers.
And the cost of this new
architecture is this,
this is the routing algorithm, right?
So basically the difference here,
the difference,
the key difference here between a regular
convolutional network is the forward
pass has an extra outer loop,
right?
So it takes far iterations over all
the units instead of one to compute the
output and the data flow looks a little,
is a little more complicated because it's
saying for every capsule that's nested
inside of a layer,
apply these operations,
whether it's a soft max
or a squashing function.
And what it does is it does make
the gradient harder to calculate.
And the model may suffer from vanishing
gradient on larger datasets which could
prevent it from scaling and
becoming the next big thing. Right?
I mean in the paper they only applied it
to em and ist not hundreds of thousands
of images.
But I suspect that this network is
going to scale really well because a,
it's Hinton and you know,
if Hinton says something's going to work,
it's probably going to work.
Okay,
so let's go ahead and look at some
code to see what this looks like.
So what I found is this tensorflow
and implementation of capsule net,
which is still in progress.
I mean this paper is relatively new,
but I found this code that we
can look at a right now. So this,
this was built in tensorflow,
right? So in this layer,
notice how it's only got two imports,
your num py in tensorflow.
So it's a really clean,
it's a clean architecture here.
So it's got this capsule,
convolutional layer, right?
So it's going to have a number of
outputs, a kernel size, you know,
these hyper parameters like striding.
And so it's got this if l
statement where it says,
if we're not going to do the routing
scheme, build it this way, but if we are,
build it this way. So let's look at
both. If we have our routing scheme,
which we should have,
it's going to say,
and we'll start off with a list of all
of our capsules and then we'll iterate
through the number of units we specified
and we'll say, okay, so for each, uh,
let's go ahead and create a convolutional
layer, like a standard tensorflow,
convolutional layer, and store that inside
of the capsules, this capsule variable.
And then we'll take the capsule variable
and appended to the capsule list, right?
And so eventually we're going to have
all of these convolutional layers inside
of this capsule slayer. So note, so
this is how it's nested, right? So,
and once we,
and once we have all of these layers,
we'll concatenate them together to proof.
We'll concatenate them together and
then we'll squash them with this novel
nonlinearity function. And so, but
if we do have this routing mechanism,
which we wish the paper had,
we'll say, okay, let's again,
we'll create a list of capsules and
then for however many outputs we want,
let's create this capsule class added to
the list and upended and then return a
tensor with the shape, right? So
if we look at this capsule, uh,
implementation right
here, this, this class,
basically this is the routing
mechanism right here, right?
Just the one that we saw right here,
this routing algorithm where it's saying,
okay, let's go through,
let's go through, uh,
let's go through the number of iterations
we want and apply these operations to
them. So notice that there
is a nonlinearity here that
the paper talked about,
which is not Relu, it's, it's a novel
nonlinearity, which looks like this.
This is, this is kind of interesting.
This, this nonlinearity that they used,
that they found,
uh,
was good for applying to a group of
neurons rather than a single drawn, right?
So for Relu we apply
it to a single neuron,
but when we're applying a nonlinearity
to a group of neurons or a capsule,
they found that this a nonlinearity works.
The works worked the best for them.
And so that's what, that's
what, uh, is, is happening here.
So that's the capsule layer.
So once we have the capsule layer,
we can import it here
into this capital network,
and then we can go ahead and
build our architecture, right?
So we'll start off by saying, okay,
so we'll start off by saying, okay,
for each layer we have a primary
capsular and we have a digit caps layer.
Let's go ahead and add our a capsule,
a capital layer to them. So these are,
these are both capsule layers,
right? So for each of these layers,
there is a nested convolutional
network inside of each of those layers,
which is a capsule.
And then inside of those capsules,
the nonlinearity is applied to it.
The,
the novel squashing function
that we saw in the paper.
And then at the very end, by the way, at
the very end of this network, after it's,
it's applied these operations
to each layer with each capsule,
it applies this decoder
algorithm. So, um, and the paper,
they found that at the end of the
network they could just use a decoder to
reconstruct a digit from
the digit caps layer.
So after it's applied this
first set of a capsule,
this first set of capsule operations,
then it then it can reconstruct the input
from that learned representation and
then apply a reconstruction loss, uh,
to improve that learned representation.
And that's what this is. This is the
reconstruction loss that is used to, uh,
learn that representation and improve
that representation over time. So, uh,
this and tensorflow implementation
is a work in progress. Uh,
I've got a link to it in the video
description has lost my slides. Uh,
but if you want you can train it. I've,
I've, I've been training it as well,
and you just need to,
all you have to do to train
it has just run python,
train.py and it'll start training and
you'll see the loss decrease over time.
Please subscribe for more
programming videos. And for now,
I'm going to learn more about capsules.
So thanks for watching.